halo infinite micro transactions and
progression are changing but how and
when
343 industries is planning some
additional changes to halo infinite's
in-game shop in a blog post the studio
said it had received lots of feedback
around the pricing of halo infinite's
micro transaction offerings and what's
available to buy in general in response
to this 343 has already begun to sell
some items from bundles individually and
it also attempted to standardize pricing
with the overall goal of lowering prices
across the board looking ahead 343 said
it agrees with the feedback that players
want even more purchasing options along
with a higher rate of rotation when it
comes to what's available not only that
but 343 teased that it might look into
adding a second page of microtransaction
items for sale halo infinite's in-game
store sells all manner of items on a
rotating basis including cat ears being
a free-to-play game the title makes
money from microtransactions so it makes
sense to hear that 343 wants to further
refine and expand the experience but
microtransactions aren't the only thing
343 wants to refine going forward for
example 343 said it understands players
want a career progression system
separate from the battle pass and this
is in the design phase now however it
might not be released anytime soon as
343 said quote we want to nail it out
the gate and that's going to take some
time additionally 343 said it has heard
the feedback that players want per match
xp the lack of this feature is something
that pushed me away from the game beyond
its initial like first couple weeks of
hype i know they change things so that
there's a challenge associated with
playing matches so you play one and you
get a certain amount and then the next
match it lowers and then the next match
it lowers but even with that system i
didn't really feel like i was
progressing thankfully the per match xp
feature is coming and is expected to
launch sometime this year and in general
343 acknowledged that players want the
halo infinite battle pass to feel as if
it's offering a greater value to players
to that end the season 2 lone wolves
battle pass will include credits to
unlock up to 1 000 credits in a single
battle pass also in the blog post 343
addressed the feedback that the halo
infinite double xp boosts run on time
and this might not be ideal already 343
increased the time for these boosts from
15 minutes to 30 and then 30 to an hour
the studio said quote long term however
we do agree with moving away from
time-based xp boosts especially with per
match xp coming in a future update we'll
have more to share on both of these at a
later date as for halo infinite's live
events 343 said it has heard the
feedback that players would like to see
more modes from several events persist
in the game after the events wrap up 343
said it intentionally removed these
modes when an event wrapped up to try to
spice up the events and convince players
to jump in but going forward 343 said
quote we will be doing a better job of
making an event content available in the
normal matchmaking rotation beginning in
season 2. this is just a very small
sampling of all the information in the
season 1 feedback report so be sure to
read the full 343 blog post to catch up
on all the details season 2 lone wolves
just got a new trailer and begins on may
3rd it adds new maps and modes including
the battle royale style last spartan
standing and in other news the tv series
is airing and has already revealed
master chief's face and his butt so now
the public has seen both sets of cheeks
and i would like to officially rename
him
master cheeks this guy stinks leave your
ratings for the halo tv show aim for
that joke in the comments below
have a great weekend